scp-049 was many things a doctor an
enemy of the pestilence a seemingly
Immortal masked anomaly contained by the
SCP Foundation but Above All Else he was
a scholar a man in constant pursuit of
knowledge whether he was conducting
whatever experiments he could get away
with in containment reading various
medical texts he was allowed upon
request or asking questions of his
fellow anomalies as they passed by his
cell he was always looking for new
information and additional subjects of
study sometimes they pertain to the
pestilence but other times they were
simply things that he engaged with for
the pure joy of Discovery and
understanding after a bout of
particularly impressive good behavior
namely a willingness to cooperate with
questions from researchers and a
record-breaking streak of days without
any reanimation of deceased tissue the
blank doctor was given the exciting
opportunity to peruse a selection of of
official SCP files any potential
compromising information was heavily
redacted of course but the doctor was
nevertheless thrilled at the chance he
greedily devoured file after file while
sipping a cup of hot tea pouring over
reports of invisible women and
Supernatural vending machines finally he
came to the file for
scp-2935 as the doctor read about the
space-time anomaly in a cave in Indiana
holding the gateway to another reality
where all life mysteriously ended his
mind began to race with possibilities
what could have wiped out everything so
efficiently in such a perfect horrible
swoop on the date of April 20th 2016. he
could only think of one explanation and
he began to obsess after days of
rereading the file again and again the
plague doctor could take no more he
requested an audience with the senior
researcher and was granted a meeting
with senior researcher son what did you
want to ask me about Dr Sun inquired
please doctor you must understand there
is so little I can do to continue my
work in my current state meanwhile the
pestilence rages on outsides of these
walls at times even within them and I
can do nothing but this he held up the
file for
scp-2935 this may hold the key to all
that I seek I only ask that you permit
me to venture inside on a research
expedition of my own you want to go into
scp-2935 Dr Sun had prepared herself for
a lot of possible requests but this was
not one of them yes doctor I do and you
you understand what that would mean Dr
Sun studied the plague doctor's face but
the mask revealed no expression but
Stony determination you wouldn't be able
to come back you would have to stay
there indefinitely I understand that is
a sacrifice I am fully prepared to make
out of one prison and into another yes
but there I will have so much to study
so much to learn perhaps I will at last
find the answers I seek Dr Sun nodded
let me speak to the higher-ups about
this I'll see what they have to say the
plague doctor waited patiently in a Cell
thinking of nothing but the verdict that
awaited him until finally Dr Sun
returned yes doctor what is it your
request has been approved Dr Suns
sounded almost surprised we'll get you
transported to Indiana tomorrow then I
suppose I must bid you and you Doctor
the plague doctor nodded solemnly
goodbye doctor Dr Sun gave him a nod in
return then turned and left scp-049 cell
for the last time the next day scp-049
was moved to a secure transport vehicle
and driven to a non-descript cemetery
near Joppa Indiana their operatives led
him to the Cave's entrance below where
it was sealed with concrete there
brought with them tools to dismantle the
concrete seal and additional concrete to
close the entrance back up once as cp049
was inside there would truly be no going
back for the plague doctor once he
embarked on this last great experiment
once the way was cleared out
scp-049 turned to face his escorts
gentlemen I thank you for your service I
only hope that I may honor it by at last
defeating the pestilence that threatens
this world unsure of what to say in
response the officers could only give
him a silent salute and the moment
before he stepped over the threshold the
plague doctor recalled a snippet of
Shakespeare he had once heard at the
theater many many years ago he repeated
it once more unthrew the breach dear
friends once more and he walked into the
unknown this strange new world was at
first indistinguishable from the old one
that the doctor had left behind it was
just like the file had said everything
was identical just entirely absent of
life that was the first detail the
plague doctor noticed the dry vegetation
poking up from the earth brown leaves
curling from petrified tree branches
pale grass parting the cracked dirt the
second detail to catch his attention was
the silence deafening silence back at
the foundation site there was always
noise the clatter of footsteps down the
hall pens scratching on clipboards
alarms blaring strange creatures wailing
in the distance d-classes screaming but
here there was nothing only the hollow
whistle of the wind in this moment as he
stood at the top of the hill staring out
at a vast landscape of emptiness the
plague doctor felt doubt creeping in had
he made a mistake coming to this place
he had hoped to find knowledge here had
hoped to unlock the secrets of the
pestilence but perhaps he had just
consigned himself to a lonely
Eternal grave but no he shook away the
feeling there was no sense in becoming
discouraged so soon when there was still
so much to discover he would explore the
landscape and see what surprises awaited
there would be time to despair later and
so the plague doctor walked he walked
past fields of cattle laying on their
sides so undisturbed they almost
appeared to be sleeping if it weren't
for their complete and utter Stillness
the lack of decomposition gave him pause
as he realized that microbial life must
have been eliminated by the world's
great dying as well he stepped around
broken Birds where they had fallen clear
out of the sky and landed on the ground
and looked pitifully at the cars parked
on the side of the road with long dead
drivers still inside the world just as
it was at the moment of collective death
it was as fascinating as it was tragic
after a long walk through the infinite
graveyard the doctor saw building up a
head that piqued his interest a hospital
left abandoned Windows caked with dust
he couldn't be sure what he hoped to
find inside but a building filled with
medical equipment and possibly beds
filled with deceased patients to examine
would be an excellent place to start
scp-049 wandered the halls of the
hospital Gathering supplies as he went
and placing them into his trusty black
bag he was admiring an IV Stan when he
heard something curious a metallic Clank
coming from down the hall it was notable
not only because the building appeared
so empty but because it was the first
sound he had heard since stepping into
the cave and leaving his world behind
could it be could something else be
alive in this place after all he
followed the sound eagerly to its source
an operating room at the end of the
hallway he opened the door and came face
to face with the last thing he ever
expected to see himself this figure was
slightly different wearing a deep red
mask instead of the doctor's signature
white but everything else was the same
from the gloved hands to the the robes
to the beak to the bag of implements and
samples At His Feet the red Mass doctor
regarded him with a pleasant curiosity
as they locked eyes hello doctor hello I
must ask my dear fellow are you me I do
believe I must be the red mask doctor
said simply I have never seen anyone
else like you before like us where did
you come from from a world much like
this one the doctor explained he went on
to tell us double the entire story from
his capture by the foundation to his
discovery of the scp-2935 file every
step of the journey that brought him to
this very place I had hoped to conduct
research and discover enough to fill my
solitude but with you here his
imagination brimmed with possibilities
you could tell me if you will what
happened to reduce the world to this
state ah the necessary cost of
scientific advancement is what happened
the red Mass doctor responded collateral
damage as to be expected in any great
Endeavor what do you mean the doctor
frowned the pestilence did this surely
innocence the red Mass doctor's eyes
glittered behind his mask as my work
progressed this result became
unavoidable you see it was the only way
to cure them one must Purge the poison
entirely if no other solution can be
found do you mean to tell me the plague
doctor struggled to find the words that
you did this oh do not look so shocked
new friend the red mask Dr scoffed if we
are alike then you certainly must have
sacrificed a great deal to the pursuit
of a cure it is for the greater good yes
yes
I suppose I have but not like this never
like this he shook his head what are we
as doctors with no more patience to
treat free the red Mass doctor smiled no
no no the doctor could not believe what
he was hearing what of Your World his
twin demanded what became of the
patience there I left them behind in
search of my cure here the doctor
retorted the red mask figure paused
thoughtfully they are all still there on
the other side of this scp-2935
why did you say the entrance was my
friend I neglected to mention it and I
never will you will not go back through
that Gateway the doctor backed away from
the red masked man and horror this
figure looked like him but he was
villainous cold and cruel oh no map I
will go to site 19 and finally file
myself after all I have all the time in
the world the redness doctor swept out
of the room leaving scp-049 stunned if
the other doctor discovered the location
of that Gateway if he returned to the
other world the same terrible fate would
befall every living thing there it was
his duty as a doctor to ensure that it
did not happen as fast as his legs could
carry him the doctor race to psych 19.
he only hoped he would not be too late
at the abandoned Foundation site the
plague doctor tore through the Halls
searching for a hint of movement for a
glint of red that might lead him to his
Wicked other if he could not find him
there was and
he dimly recalled overhearing the
location of an emergency switch only to
be flipped in the most dire of
circumstances when all else was lost now
was the time for such a switch the
plague doctor knew just as he had the
switch in his sights the plague doctor
heard a voice behind him you'll really
not stop me why not join me we could be
colleagues battling the pestilence
together the red Mass doctor held out a
hand in invitation you are as follow a
plague as the pestilence itself the
plague doctor hissed then I would leave
you here alone the red Mass doctor spat
neither you nor I will leave this place
I will make sure of it the plague doctor
reached for the switch as the
realization dawned on the other doctor's
face the red Mass doctor lunged
desperately at his counterpart but it
was too late the plague doctor flipped
the switch and the countdown began the
on-site nuclear warhead Was preparing to
detonate you the red Mass doctor hissed
see Swift kill us both it may but on the
other side of that Great Divide they
shall live the plank doctor replied see
pestilence will take them all the plague
doctor shook his head perhaps you are
right but I believe they will find a way
to fight you and I will not get the
chance to see who is correct I fear but
I have made my peace with that you've
ruined everything the red Mass doctor
insisted but the playing doctor did not
hear he was already closing his eyes
listening to the countdown once more he
murmured to himself until the bleach the
tinny voice over the speakers counted
down three two one now go check out
scp-049 cures scp-096 of the pestilence
and scp-049 what actually is the
pestilence the plague doctor questions
and theories for more plague doctor